The question I get asked more than anything
lately is, how can you say that Revenge of
the Sith was a good movie?
But after that, and I have my reasons, the
next most asked question is, who do you trust
in the media?
I'm finding this question harder and harder
to answer, which is yet another indication
of how screwed up our political and social
system is right now.
At the same time, it's hard to know just how
screwy our world is, or whether it's just
the loudest and craziest voices get amplified
on social media.
Maybe the American revolution actually was
a bit nuttier than the history books say,
but we'll never know, as George Washington
didn't have the chance to live tweet it.
Without trust, we really don't have the basic
underpinings for a free and pluralistic society.
We have to trust our elected officials will
do the jobs they're sworn in to do and carry
out the promises they said they would deliver
upon.
We have to trust our media will keep the political
elite in check and not just suck up to the
powers that be, and we have to trust our institutions
are strong enough to withstand corrupt politicians
and totalitarian ideologies that would strip
us from the very freedoms our system was built
upon.
Of course, trust, without doing the necessary
work to make sure it's based in logic and
reason, is just faith.
Having faith our politicians will do the right
thing, or our media will hold the politicians
to account, or that our system will just function
as it should, is basically a recipe for disaster.
Slowly but surely our freedoms will be chipped
away at because faith isn't what guarantees
our freedoms, it is the constitution that
does so.
Trust is built over time by repeated evidence
that you can actually believe that when someone
says something it's what they mean.
You don't believe it simply because they say
it, you believe it because of a track record
of a person consistently following through
on their word.
This is the opposite of faith, which is built
on the idea of believing in something without
evidence.
We usually talked about these existential
issues in the context of god and religion,
but I think it would serve us all well to
ask some important questions about these issues
right here and right now.
So now let me kick that question back to you?
Who do you trust in the media?
I'm guessing it's a pretty short list, though
if you've some good names I'd love to hear
them in the comment section below.
And let's go a step further, who do you trust
in politics?
If you're the biggest Trump supporter out
there, do you truly trust everything that
he says?
Or do you accept his untruths because you
believe in his wider agenda?
Accepting a certain amount of untruth may
be the only legitimate way to view politics
and politicians, but when you add distrust
of the media to distrust of politicians and
toss in a heavy dose of social media craziness,
we end up with this confused conversation
in which we can't even agree on basic facts.
This spot, where nothing is really true and
what we feel overrides what is provable, is
fertile ground for those on the extremes to
take root.
So who do I trust?
Well there's a wide range of people from Sam
Harris to Ben Shapiro to Larry Elder and Eric
Weinstein.
Trusting these people doesn't mean they're
infallible or I agree with everything they
say, but it does mean I see they have a commitment
to the truth and have consistently done their
best to put it out there.
They don't have all the answers and either
do I, but we're doing our best to find some
truth in the sea of craziness.
For those of us who genuinely want to figure
out how to combat the forces of who want to
burn down the system or give into authoritarian
tyranny our work is cut out for us.
As for me, I trust that it'll work out because
I see more and more of you speaking out everyday.
You might say that a little faith in yourself
goes a long way...